من المونديال ومن الليله القاسيه على شرق
القارات الاسيويه حيث انهت البرازيل
وكرواتيا احلام كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
باقصائهما من كاس العالم وانهاء احلامهما
عند الدور 16 البرازيل تلاعبت بدفاعات
المنتخب الكوري وسحقته باربعه اهداف مقابل
هدف في مباراه استعراضيه لنجوم السمبار
اما كرواتيا فاحتاجه لركلات الحظ من اجل
تفوق على المنتخب الياباني العنيد لتنتهي
رحله المنتخبات الاسيويه في مونديال قطر
20 22 المزيد عن هذه الارقام التي سجلت
امس معك لميس
العديد من الارقام والاحصائيات سجلت خلال
مباريات يوم امس بعد تاهل برازيل وكرواتيا
على حسابي كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
البرازيل اكملت مسيرتها الناجحه امام
المنتخبات الاسيويه في كاس العالم محققه
انتصارها الرابعه على منتخبات القاره
البرازيل ايضا تسجل ثاني مره في تاريخها
بمباراه اقصائيه اكثر مما سجلت بدور
المجموعات كاملا منذ مونديال عام
1978 اما بالنسبه لكرواتيا فقد وصلت للمره
الثالثه بتاريخ المشاركها بكاس العالم
للدور ربع النهائي بعد مونديال 1998 و2018
تمتلك كرواتيا سجل الناصع بركلات الجزاء
في كاس العالم بعد فوزها على الدنمارك
وروسيا في 2018 واليابان في 2022 اليابان
تخفق مره جديده في الفوز بمباراه
الاقصائيه في كاس العالم بعد خسارتها
للمره الرابعه بتاريخ مشاركاتها في نفس
المرحله بعد ركلات الترجيح بين واليابان
وصلت عدد الركلات الترجيحيه المسجله الى
200 مقابل 87 ضائعه بتاريخ المونديال
[تصفيق]
من الدوحه يا منورنا كل صباح مراسل صباح
العربيه نايف سجين نايف يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك امس رحله نهايه رحله المنتخبات
الاسيويه على يد البرازيل وكرواتيا حدثنا
كيف كانت اجواء المباريات والخروج الاسيوي
من المونديال
ااا طبعا ااا سهام خلينا في البدايه نتكلم
عن المنتخب الكرواتي والمنتخب الياباني
كلنا يعني شاهدنا احداث المباراه ولكن
دعينا نتحدث عن ما بعد المباراه في
الكواليس يعني كان هناك عدم رضا على
المستوى الذي قدمه المنتخب الكرواتي
والاداء الذي قدمه وكان يعني سبب كبير
للجماهير الكويتيه وايضا حتى لوسائل
للاعلام هنا بسبب ان المنتخب همم يذهب
بعيدا في مونديال بسبب المستوى الذي يقدمه
في الفتره الماضيه اما في اليابان هناك
يعني بالرغم انه يعني كان ادائهم رائع جدا
وقدموا مستوى مميز وفرضه سيطرتهم لكن
اليابانيين لم ااه انساهم هذا الامر عن
همم خطتهم نعلم ان اليابان وضعت خطه طويله
الماده تقريبا اكثر من 40 عام حتى عام 20
خمسه وخمسين هذه الخطه لديها مؤشرات بتاعه
واهداف اذا لم تتحقق معناها ان هناك خلل
ضمن هذه الخطه ان يصل منتخب اليابان في 20
22 الى دوره الثمانيه
ونعلم انه المنتخب خرج من منذ 16 لذلك كان
هناك بالامس مطالبات كبيره بالتحقيق في
اسباب عدم همم تحقيق اهداف الخطه واذا كان
هناك امور اثرت على هذا الامر همم وليتم
تداركها حتى تسير الخطه حسب ما وضعت وتحقق
اهدافها في همم المرحله المقبله في نقطه
لافته همم
بالامس يعني رغم الشعبيه الكبيره للمنتخب
البرازيلي وايضا حتى المنتخب الكرواتي بعد
وصافته
للمونديال همم روسيا الماضي لان يعني انا
لما همم شخصيه لانه في تعاطف مع المنتخب
الاسيويه يعني كان في تعاطف كبير مع
المنتخب الياباني كان في تعاطف كبير مع
المنتخب همم الكوري كان في جماهير عربيه
تدعم قبيل ال- ال- الاسيا الاسيويين هناك
يعني حاله يعني انا اشوف انها ايجابيا
وعمال دائما المنتخبات الاقل همم
يعني متعاطف مع اليابان وكوريا وعم تهاجم
كرواتيا واداءها رغم انها فايزه
همم انا همم كنت بكمل لك الموضوع وانا من
ضمنهم ترى من ضمن المجموعه اللي دائما
تتعاطف مع المنتخبات الاقل يعني وانا
لاحظتها يمكن لاني في المونديال سهام فايش
الاجواء وتاثر فيها
دائما الدعم لكل المنتخبات الاقل يبغون
تكون توصل لمراحل متقدمه ودائما الاثاره
متى تكون يعني امس فوز البواسير كل شافه
طبيعي لكن لو تخيل لو فازت همم كوريا هنا
بيكون الحدث همم
حتى بالنسبه لان احنا ك- اعلاميه داخل
المونديال طبعا الصخب مكتمل ومجتمع همم
كريستيانو رونالدو دائما يعني المصاعب
واعتقد انه يعيش فتره صعبه جدا يعني تخيلي
النجم ال- ال- ال- نجم البرتغال الاول همم
70% من المشاركين في الاست طلبوا بيبعاد
كريستيانو عن تشكيل الاساسيه هذا يعني امر
كبير يناير هو اخر مباراه للملعب 974
الاول في العالم القابل للتفكير
صح
همم على فكره كل الملعبين حتى استاد
الجنوب
كانت امس اخر مباراه همم سيتم تخفيض مقاعد
استاد الجنوب من 40,000 الى الى 20,000
حتى يعني يستوعب بالاحداث التي ستقام في
قطر في الفتره المقبله وكما يعني ذكرنا
ملعب
907 او 74 اصلا سهام انت اللي بتشوفي
المكان وهو مقام بالقرب من الميناء يعني
حتى ما كان مؤقت همم قريب من الميناء بعيد
شويه عن همم عن وسط همم الدوحه همم فهو من
الاساس التخطيط له حتى اختيار مكانه حتى
محطه المترو همم سهام ما توصل قريب من من
اسماء لانه سوري 174 حاويه في الميناء
شكرا جزيلا تبقى معنا يا نايف لانه الحديث
عن المونديال بقيه سن رعود اليك بعد قليل